monsieur le président durant le long
combat que vous avez menées pour
l'émancipation de la tunisie vous êtes
toujours montré fidèle à vous même et
j'aimerais vous demander aujourd'hui
quels sont les grands principes qui ont
guidé votre action que la force de notre
pâte y résider dans le contact avec le
peuple
c'est en élevant le niveau du peuple en
lui faisant comprendre ses droits le
droit le sens de la dignité le sens de
l'honneur
c'est ce contact continuel par la bouche
la boîte non pas simplement par les
journaux comment j'y suis allé avec mon
auto j'avais une auto ainsi si un autre
tué toute la tunisie dans tous les
recoins dans les montagnes dans les
plaines dans le sud dans le nord
c'était un travail extraordinaire c'est
comme ça que j'ai formé le peuple et que
j'ai créé ce vaste sentiment d'affection
et de gratitude n'est ce pas que vous
voyez partout
selon de bourguiba parce que j'ai
circulé dans tout le pays sans aucune
autorisation
la réaction du gouvernement quand elle
en avait assez
c'est devant voyez l'espoir en exil
n'est ce pas ou en prison
eh bien je continuais l'espoir mon
travail quand je sors de prison de
l'exil bowden de trois ans
c'est pour reprendre n'est ce pas mes
méthodes de propagande
monsieur le président c'est votre
premier voyage officiel
j'aimerais vous demander comment vous le
concevez ce que c'est le couronnement de
toute votre oeuvre ou est-ce que c'est
au contraire une nouvelle impulsion que
vous les donner à aux bons rapports
entre la france et c'est un peu les deux
vous savez c'est un couronnement par la
fois cinquante années de lutte passe pas
mais comme cette lutte là avait pour but
justement de nous permettre de coopérer
d'élever le niveau du peuple n'est ce
pas de sortir du sous développement
n'est ce pas eh bien la france s'est
toujours trouvé là pour nous aider
de sorte que mon voyage c'est pour moi
un grand moment et pour le mot deux pays
renforcement des liens économiques
culturels tous les liens possibles
imaginables militaire il faut non plus
nous n'avons plus de deux complexes
j'aime et j'ai combattu un demi siècle
le sang n est ce pas parce que j'ai été
formé mais un peu à la française j'ai
connu les facultés françaises lycées et
10 pour les écoles vers l'horizon et la
téléprésence pour beaucoup de prison
lorsque vous considérez le long chemin
parcouru par la tunisie et que vous
faites le point de sa situation actuelle
quels sont les problèmes prioritaires
qui vous apparaissent des loups et la
fin de la lutte
nous avons commencé ce que nous avons
appelé la grande lutte estimant que la
lutte pour l'indépendance
c'est une petite lutte la grande lutte
la lutte pour le développement
c'est la lutte pour élever le niveau du
pape pour sortir du sous développement
pour rattraper les pays disent pas
civilisés qui ont leur industrie qui on
a une culture de science c'est pour ça
que nous avons donné un grand grand
crédit n'est ce pas pour l'instruction
la france m'a aidé dans une très grande
mesure qui concerne les professeurs
passent par les instituteurs et nous
savons maintenant des cadres valables
début nous n'avions même pas n'est ce
pas de quatre fois en tenir l'exploit de
l'administration moi je suis optimiste
quand on parle de la tunisie d'après le
bol du magic
ouais je crois que j'ai fait quelque
chose de solide qui tiendra
[Musique]